there are way tricks that people use to
learn is to store more numbers that way
is it's very bored of the exercise at
learning I bet that relying too much on
your notebook or your blackberry or
whatever it does not help in this
direction because we are confident that
we do not need to learn but because as I
said at the beginning attention is very
important so if you do not pay enough
attention because you write that kind of
thing then obviously you will learn rest
so the secret would be just a minute
obviously if you repeat 10 times the
same thing you have more chances to
learn it or if you use association with
in what you're learning with something
else and you store this association in
in the brain then then you will remember
that particular thing better than
another so it's a there are ways people
uses and to memorize and and then there
are also exceed in our difference
between one person to the other for
instance I'm very bad with member
numbers but a much better will remember
geographical names location etc so I bet
there are people are better remember no
news notes in music than others depends
also what you like it what you don't
like just because you pay more attention
to what you like and what you don't like
as I said before the only thing this
issue is just to exercise your brain and
just like you do with the gym nor with
your muscles and that's for sure should
help because the brain we have to see
the brain also like like an organ it has
a reserve so if we built up bigger
reserve and then when diseases will heat
or the main we program we will start
occurring you will have more time to
compensate for the for the problem so it
diseases should be start later and
slower and just not that we will avoid
the disease but it almost likely what we
scientists think most likely happen is
just with more reserved in the brain so
that's for sure I have to say also that
although it needs to be confirmed
validated and one cannot exclude it to
end up like with the aluminum story that
you know people say that died like the
Mediterranean diet with the present of
antioxidant this kind of stuff in your
type they should protect and against the
problem like health and this or be more
protected which does not mean again that
the does not mean that it will not
happen but it will happen there will be
less incidence of Alzheimer disease in
this population or a population that eat
fish and fish this time is obviously we
have to be careful because there's
things showing it but they might not be
confirmed in the future but that's what
in the exercise and eating healthy
it's not tell the memory also others
problems
whatever you you like to do and it's not
just yet to take it like a pill now I
have to do trend across word puzzle and
instead of five it does not it doesn't
work like that it just to be involved
with your life and and being active and
not fortunately when sometime people
become all that they tend to be less
stressed out by life and they all right
that tend to be depressed so let's
involve less interested so that's the
thing is just to be active mentally
active and to be mentally active I bet
you need to like what you are doing i
mean you cannot oblige yourself to be
mentally active i have to be mentally
that i don't think it works like that